one of the Philippines most prominent
journalists and one of her colleagues
have been found guilty of libel and in
case seen as a major blow to Press
Freedom Day Raisa denies the charges
over an article on her news website
Rattler linking a businessman to
criminal activity the site was has
reported an on extrajudicial killings
and abuses during president rodrigo de
terre days time in office she faces up
to six years in prison and is expected
to appeal the conviction now the case is
the first of at least eight filed
against I said senator Tate came to
office in 2016
they include alleged tax evasion and
foreign ownership that are banned in the
Philippines the cyber libel case stems
from a two thousand seventeen complaint
filed by a businessman over a rattler
story published in 2012 before the
cybercrime law was passed or Predaking
says he was defamed when he was linked
to the then Supreme Court justice who
was later removed from office for
failing to declare assets the libel
complaint was dismissed in 2018 but
government investigators later reversed
that decision the arrest joins us live
now from Manila Maria thank you very
much for your time I guess first or your
reaction to this disbelief at first but
then again I can't really say that
because I had expected the book to be
thrown at me I had expected a conviction
I had expected worse conditions it's a
very strange time and my you know you go
through an emotional roller coaster by
the time it hit me we've we've crossed
another boundary you know the in 2016
the government attacks on social media
said that they would try to turn the
journalist label to criminal it took
four years and here we are I've now been
convicted but of course we will fight
this in court what are the types of ways
that obviously this is the most
egregious way in which your job has
become impossible to do but along the
way what were the things that you were
seeing that you can tell this was going
in a bad direction
I think the weaponization of social
media was the first and this was in 2016
we did one of the first stories around
the world to look at how Facebook
algorithms in
pack democracy for the series that we
called the propaganda war I was attacked
and that kind of weaponization the
narratives that were there that's where
I became a criminal or Eddie that then
translated into the law a year later the
same attacks came out of President to
tear test mouths and then now it took
you know four years but now the court
has joined in this insidious attack on
press freedom and the attempt to stifle
are the rights that are in the
Constitution the number of attack of
cases that have been filed in 2018 11
cases against us and then in 2019
multiple arrests and detention and now
seven other criminal cases you know so I
guess I I know what is coming it's it's
like looking at a train wreck happening
in slow motion but we're still standing
we're going to fight back
and while there's a veneer of rule of
law we're going to make sure that every
signature every name judgment SS court
today made a decision that will that is
now in written down in stone that's a
new point when you say we are going to
fight back
who are the allies of press freedom who
are your allies in that country I
actually think a lot more because you
know again these attacks have been going
on for a while but just in 2023 big
things happened a very militaristic
pandemic lockdown the second is just
about a month ago on May 5th President
to tear the administration essentially
shut down abs-cbn the largest
broadcaster the largest news group in
this country and then just last week the
House of Representatives passed an
anti-terror bill that is essentially
going to codify institutionalized
a lot of these these abuses of power and
once the president turns this into law
you could be arrested without a warrant
if you are a government if you're
questioning the government you could be
named a terrorist you could be held in
prison for 24 days without a warrant
these are new things and I think that's
that's why I feel like we're crossing
another milestone with this decision
because it is codifying into law two
major processes you know in order the
legal acrobatics have happened to get
this case the court is incredible the
first one is that they actually had to
change the statute of limitations for
libel from one year to twelve years and
then they introduced a novel concept of
republication continuous publication
because the law that we supposedly
violated didn't exist when we publish
this story when we corrected a
typographical error two years later that
is the basis of bringing this case to
court so I'm really so answer me this
what effect obviously what you're going
through is the most extreme but there's
a spectrum of the type of effect that
this has on other journalists how do you
think this is affecting other
journalists are they scared to do their
jobs I think that was at the beginning
it's four years in and I think I'm
hoping that that journalists will see
and I made this appeal when I talked to
them that we must do our jobs because if
we don't exercise that those rights will
be taken away from us and I think this
stands for you know all the rights that
are guaranteed in the Constitution
because it sits on the public's right to
know freedom of speech freedom of the
press I'm hoping we're waking up I hate
to be the one you know we're the
cautionary tale the chilling effect
happened years ago and now there is
enough of a track record the shutting
down of abs-cbn being the one before me
and then here a conviction for libel of
a story I never had a hand in you didn't
you know and and one of the things that
was that made me both angry and made me
laugh was there's a part in the
judgement where the judge actually
and malice by saying that my title
executive editor is and this is in her
words a clever ruse to evade
responsibility that I had that title
before this case was filed and I'll keep
it you know so we're gonna challenge
this in court judgment essa made I think
she dealt the blow to press freedom but
it isn't over a clever title Wow well
you are a very smart woman you are very
clever miss maria reza thank you so much
for joining us we appreciate it thanks
for having me all right